Welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
Marvel released a new eternals trailer video.
So we'll break it down there's a bunch of
new Easter eggs and a couple cool references
to other comic book characters.
So if you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos, Eternals
is like the next big marvel movie this coming
out the beginning of November to start seeing
a lot more footage for another's a lot of
questions about what's going on with kit harington's
black knight character some of the celestials
the history of the MCU that they'll be telling
so try to explain that during this video.
But starting with the new footage you have
Ikaris in the UK in London still when they're
fighting this large deviant this is all meant
to be part of that larger scene where there
saving kit harington's Dane Whitman black
knight character.
The way they explain it is that Ikaris obviously
has this historical relationship with Circe's
character, the goes back 7000 years.
Like they were a couple they were married
for a long time but jump to present day for
the last hundreds and hundreds of years.
So far the eternals have kind of gone their
separate ways.
Just because there are that many threats all
just started living normal lives amongst humans
the movie picks up Ikaris is still kind of
in love with Circe, but they haven't been
together for hundreds and hundreds of years.
And she started this relationship with kit
harington's black knight character because
they both work at the natural history Museum
in London.
This is also part of the clues of how Dane
Whitman starts learning about his black knight
heritage in the legacy of his family.
But when this fight scene is happening you
see him fly up in the air and uses I-beams
to take out this deviant here.
If you notice the background of the buildings
on the street in the site here.
The same buildings from this big bus scene
where Sersi uses her powers to transmute the
bus into a bunch of flowers to say kit harington's
character and he's like wait what what just
happened were all these flowers were to the
bus go make all the kit harington jokes that
you want here John Snow still knows nothing.
You also see sprites character create a bunch
of copies of herself kind of like Loki creates
copies of himself as allusions illusions are
one of her powers.
You can see her use those in some of the other
flashback scenes was right after this scene
in the London area where they basically have
to explain to kit harington's black knight
character who they are what eternals are
with their mission is and then obviously the
question is asked why didn't you guys help
out with thanos probably the biggest question
that everybody asked mostly because aeration
the judge the prime Celestial told them not
to is a core part of their mission do not
interfere unless it involves the deviance
yes I do know there's the big question like
what's going on with thanos is he supposed
to be part deviant this a lot of misconceptions
about this the technical way to explain Thanos
is that he's an eternal from Titan, but he
has the deviant mutation.
So he still eternal like from the ground up,
but he just looks purple like that.
Where is the rest of his family were not purple
is the deviant mutation the gives in that
purple space grimace appearance, but genetically
he still basically an eternal so if you want
to get really technical with whether or not
they could've gotten involved because of his
deviant mutation you could say that it's kind
of a gray area.
But obviously the real answer is that Marvel
was ready to introduce those characters in the movies
But then is that other new scene of Ikaris
and Sersi going around trying to bring the
whole team of eternal's back together and
present day, because the emergence and they
just come to Phastos' house where he's living
with a full-blown family in the suburbs like
any normal human.
That's also before the scene where they have
that funny vibranium moment where he smashes
the table like, look at all the crazy stuff
that you must engineer here.
Even though that vibranium scene is meant
to be just a funny moment.
The whole connection is because fast dose
is the person amongst the eternals who creates
things like he engineers things, but also
the vibranium connection is that sometimes
around the universe where vibranium pops up
the celestials can use it to create their
bodies one of the theories is that the celestials
actually plan to use the vibranium mound in
wakanda the one of the Black Panther has been
using this whole time for the creation of
this new Celestial as part of the emergence
the whole joke about the little kid yelling
about him on TV wearing the Capon Ikaris saying
I don't where Kate and him shooting laser
beams the way they use this in the movie in
the trailer, it sounds more like a Superman
Easter egg don't think we've ever had any
legit DC comics, Easter eggs in marvel movies.
Maybe some subtle references that you could
point to but no real big Easter eggs for any
DC comic book characters.
I think mostly to avoid any potential lawsuits.
Even though technically if you watch like
the DCTV shows they reference Marvel characters
on those all the time.
Like on the flash TV show.
They mentioned the hulk several times.
But you could also say this Kate joke or joke
is an incredible's reference like no capes
you could call it a Thor reference any other
marvel character with the Cape like vision
also had a Kate and shut a laser beam out
of his forehead white vision also does the same thing
Even though his mind stone was replace with
the special weaponized crystal.
If you not a big comic book reader you can
also call this a sly reference to the Sentry
or even Hyperion.
If you not a big comic book reader both Sentry
and Hyperion are kind of like marvel's versions
of Superman they're both nearly indestructible
they can fly and they both have heat vision
some of them have other powers beyond that
to like Sentry for instance is meant to be
in insane version of Superman like what if
Superman, but make him totally insane kind
of like homelander in a PG-13 kind of way
rest homelander on the boys is like the hard
our version of a dark Superman in the funny
thing we just had falcon and winter soldier
with the whole weapons plus super soldier
storyline the Sentry's origin story is actually
part of the captain America super soldier
serum program.
Like the weapons plus program.
But Marvel hasn't really been using the Sentry
character in the comics that much recently.
And I don't think they have any plans for
him in the marvel movies anytime soon.
I think mostly to avoid any unfair comparisons
to Superman in any potential lawsuits with
Warner Bros. and DC and they already have
so many God tear powerful characters in the
marvel movies right now.
Like how many characters do you need with
laser beams shooting out of their eyes the
fly around this another scene of Kro and Angelina
Jolie'shena character in this.
They have a really weird relationship in the
comics.
Like they actually have a relationship in
the comics, but I don't know that they're
going to do that in the movies.
The whole thing with Kro is these the leader
of the deviance and they want the celestial
that's growing inside planet Earth to emerge
and destroy the planet.
There is a rumor that Dan Stevens is actually
playing the character.
But he's just kinda made some jokes about
it made some subtle allusions to it, he's
not listed on IMDb.
But that really doesn't mean anything and
he was seen with the entire cast where they
were filming earlier.
That done videos in the past about how the
eternals movie is also helping to set up the
concept of mutants inside the MCU the X-Men
characters, but a lot of you remember Dan
Stevens also played the Legion character.
Another God tear powerful X-Men mutant character
whose the natural born son of Professor X
and has a thousand different personalities
each one with its own unique mutant powers
was a little while when the next he seemed
like they might be able to get Patrick Stewart
to show up on that TV show as his version
of Professor X.
To say that he was his father they wind of
doing a slightly different direction and using
a much younger version of Professor X just
explained why it wasn't Patrick Stewart.
But funny coincidence here talking about game
of thrones actors having reunions inside marvel
movies and marvel, TV shows, because there
so many game of thrones actors in the Eternals movie
Like John Snow and Robb Stark.
On the Legion series, his father Professor
X was played by Harry Lloyd who was Viserys
Targaryen on game of thrones is a little more
footage of Gilgamesh and the other internals
fighting the deviance in the distant past.
And then more footage of them in their armor
and what seems like present day.
Saying let's finish this Angelina Jolie's
Thena character is kind of batting some molten
lava way way they keep hyping up this erupting
volcano spewing rock and lava everywhere in
all the trailers makes it seem like this is
the location where the slumbering Celestial
is been growing inside earth is going to literally
come out of like literally emerge from the
reason why they needed so many infinity gauntlet
snap strip finishes maturation process so
that it could basically wake up it releases
a certain amount of cosmic energy is just
the more infinity stones you use like when
you're using the full gauntlet it releases
crazy levels of cosmic energy in the celestials
need those in order basically create more
celestials and during the Big Bang when the
first celestial host was created when many
of the celestials were created.
There were just way more of that cosmic energy
around and they used it all to create the
celestials the you see towering around so
cut to present day when they want to create
another Celestial, which they're doing inside
planet Earth.
It just takes millions and millions of years,
because there only trace elements of this
cosmic energy they need the infinity gauntlet
snaps just really really sped that up then
even though we don't get a ton of kit harington
black knight footage during this the whole
idea during the movie is that he is basically
a story in working at the British natural history museum
So is already predisposed to be looking at
history and that's kind of how he learns about
the internals characters, but through that
that's also how he discovers the legacy of his family
The legacy the black knight the connection
to the internals characters is that they would've
been around for the original Black Knight
Ser Percy Percy black knight from marvel comics
who would be his ancestor the first person
to bear the curse and he'll become full blown
black knight with the armor with the ebony
blade in Marvel sequels to the eternals or
other spinoff movies or like Avengers 5, because
Kevin Feige did say they have big plans for
the character in kit harington also said that
he did want to come back and more marvel movies.
But if you any big questions are you spotted
any big Easter eggs in this that I didn't
talk about in my previous trailer videos just
right them blown the comments Alfred at all
your questions the my future bonus videos
I'll do a lot more internals videos as we
get closer to the movie coming out there using
it to set up a bunch of stuff in the MCU.
Not just the black knight character.
Not just the celestials.
Not just the internals but also mutants in
X-Men in the background to everyone click
here for my venom let there be carnage post
credit scene video and click here for my marvel
what if episode 9 trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!